is what we see what missing what kind of
equation could a craft that would get me
out of not really the natural numbers
not only vintages not only the rational
numbers even out of the real numbers rap
ok yeah ok
this will be I mean they're all just
examples right expense one equals zero
now uses the same kinds of rules and
operations to get my solution from here
to here right
my solution to this is going to be and
we're gonna use to lie to you okay so
try and squeeze it in it's gonna be
firstly plus or minus the square root of
well that one's going to come over the
other side which leads me negative one
yeah and then I take the square root
okay
now this number is not real you can't
measure it you can't say
unlike the square root of five which is
like you know that distance between two
and three this is not between any
numbers that we know about up here right
unlike you know this is just these
numbers facing in the direction this is
just between whole numbers and this is
again between home between national
numbers but this guy's not between any
than others you know about right you
can't place him on the number line so we
call him a whole other thing we use an
eye to indicate imaginary we call these
imaginary numbers now I'm going to talk
on Wednesday about why they called
imaginary numbers as it turns out
there's a terrible name for those
numbers they are just as real as the
real numbers but it's what we've got so
well it's real it is real so I'll talk
more about that on Wednesday this set of
numbers descendants are what we talk
about when we need the complex numbers
they are more than just the real numbers
they are bigger than that now he's
what's really profound and I like yes
yes yes sir I'll talk about that in a
second okay now here's the really really
cool thing this is why my table has this
many rows and no more if what you're
doing is try to arrive at numbers by
means of algebra and counting numbers if
these are your building blocks and these
you're building tools okay
this complex numbers these are the end
of the line there is no other kind of
number that you can combine plus minus
times divide and counting numbers
there's nothing else you can make out of
this in fact there's a speed you can
look it up later important theorem in
mathematics called but fundamental
theorem of algebra you know something's
really a big deal and they say
fundamental what it states is that any
polynomial so you see these are all
polynomials I mean the middle V's are
very supportive speeches linear but I
could make a couple more complicated
faculty any polynomial with complex
coefficients so that's these numbers in
here these numbers out the front any
polynomial with complex coefficients it
will only have complex roots this is the
end of the line one like every other
kind of number for instance you can make
an equation with just counting numbers
but its solutions I'm not counting
numbers right they might be you can make
us an equation with irrational numbers
right and it's solutions will not be
rational numbers there is something else
but once you get to complex numbers you
can't make anything more right there's
another fancy phrase for this firstly by
the way all of these guys all of these
sets belong to you because they were
built by algebra then what we call
imaginably the algebraic numbers okay
the complex numbers all we call it
algebraically closed set algebraically
closed meaning that when you construct
equations with these complex numbers you
can stay the answer stay with him the
complex numbers whether whereas I can
create equations with other kinds of
numbers and get out of there all of
these are made with counting numbers
right okay so this fundamental idea that
I can have a negative number underneath
the square root
and it isn't just like meaningless like
you just ignore it okay actually it's
something that I can work with that's
the basic assumption we're going to plug
with and it's gonna be one heck of a
ride
okay so you subheading complex
arithmetic as it turns out complex
numbers despite how weird they sound
like you can't do operations sorry you
can't do measurements on to my own
how far is I centimeters it doesn't
quite work like that we can do
operations on them just like we can with
any of the other numbers okay with some
interesting other conclusions in the
same way that you know all the rules you
learn for normal counting numbers
rational and cetera they apply to
irrational numbers sort of right so for
instance if you multiply together two
numbers like 2 times 3 right that's the
same as 3 times 2 you agree with that
right and if you take you know cert you
can take the square root of 2 times the
square root of 3 that's still the same
as the square root of 3 times it's
greater 2 so these rules apply but not
all of them apply right for instance 2
plus 3 is equal to a number right fine
but the square root of 2 plus is greater
3 does it equal the square root of 5
right because something different is
happening with these numbers okay so we
can't simply take everything that we
know and apply them here as you will see
let's
as you will see things quickly start to
break down if you try and do this right
oops I skipped a step
sorry okay so the rules apply but they
don't know we have to be a little bit
careful with them which is why there's
this whole idea it's all other branch
political things are in the table okay
so first let's lay down some notation
and some definitions so okay so in case
you wanted to know right the reason why
this is starting to break down is
because we are working into we're
walking into complex territory yeah one
is equal to minus 1 times minus 1 that's
okay right the square root of negative 1
times the square root of negative 1
really is negative 1 that's okay where
the problem is is here now the question
is why and we will get to that as we
unpack a little bit further okay
so here we go let's not I'm gonna
introduce you the basic number the basic
printing will we use for indicating all
complex numbers just like when you've
got an unknown in real numbers we use X
when you've got an unknown and you're in
complex on the way we use in I am going
to highly highly encourage that you put
a dash through all of yours ends so you
do not think that they are twos okay
believe me you only need to lose one
mark to realize why do I write my cells
like to use just save yourself the
trouble I put a dash to it so complex
numbers are in this form X plus y what
does that mean X is that real number
just like you've been using real numbers
before it can be positive negative
rational a square root that's all fine
then you've got in addition to this real
part over here you've got a part which
is a multiple of this guy right and hold
all the square root of -1 now when I
first started video complex numbers I
was like why my screen is nice one why
not scared of - - OH - me or whatever
and the reason why is because everything
is a product every imaginary number is a
product of the script - what for
instance the square root of negative 2
right is really just the square root of
2 times the square root of -1 that's
actually ok so this is the square root
of 2 times I so I can write every square
root of a negative number in terms of
this one so this is there like a
fundamental piece of your life so if we
get reject on the best base I've got a
real part and I've got this part of here
which is imaginary we've got 2 pieces to
it and they don't mix together they're a
bit like when you've got another let's
go back in on your rational lab if I had
2 plus root 3 this is an irrational
robot right but I thought I can't mix
those bits together they stay apart
they're like oil and water just like
this real and imaginary bit ok so we
call this guy the X we call him the real
component of Zen
ok Rab abbreviation for real ok the real
part is in is just X it would mix
likewise there's an imaginary part this
part the imaginary part of Z is just Y
ok so it's the size of the imaginary
part it doesn't include an eyes in it ok
yeah it's like the magnitude of it right
now being that you've got these two
parts and they're separate to each other
that's why it's sad despite being one
number
he's one number with we've got just
simple he's got you know complexity to
it and some complex numbers ok what they
mean is there's more than just a simple
number going on here is this mr. bossman
ok so a little bit of extra language
here if the real part of a complex
number the real part of the compass
lamothe these it's 0 if it's 0 right
I've got 0 plus just an imaginary part
right so we call that purely
imaginary there's no real part to it
okay and conversely if I go over here
and I say if the imaginary part is 0
then the number is purely real there are
no bits to it that have eyes flying
around so I guess by pure we mean its
undiluted there are no extra bits
hanging around ok
one last bit here the Zed is equal to X
plus it's just adding iy X&Y themselves
are real numbers
ok so I'm just gonna put over here on
the side x and y go along to the set of
real numbers ok so this is why I said no
this is the right time you need to know
this notation for all the different sets
because you need to know what numbers
they're talking about